okay good good afternoon my name is
Pippa Mills and I'm Deputy Chief
Constable here in Essex Police
we've been progressing our
investigations at the scene here in
Gray's throughout the day in order to
ensure that we maintain the dignity of
the people who've sadly lost their lives
we will be moving the lorry and the
trailer shortly once that movement has
happened we will remain here to complete
some scene examinations before we can
allow all the business operators back to
their premises I would like to thank
them for their cooperation and support
throughout the day this matter has
attracted national and international
interest and it's absolutely imperative
that the operation is conducted with the
utmost respect for the 39 people who
have lost their lives the lorry in the
trailer will be moved to a secure
location it's Hillberry docks so the
bodies can be recovered whilst
preserving the dignity of the victims
we're yet to identify them and must
manage this sensitively with their
families I appreciate how much attention
this incident will continue to attract
and the public and media appetite to
understand what's happened we also need
to understand what has happened and
Essex police will be working with all of
our partners to ensure this happens as
quickly as possible may I remind you all
that we have a 25 year-old man in
custody on suspicion of murder I will
not be commenting on speculation of the
identity of this man I ask of you all
that this time is please if you have any
information which could help our
investigation please contact my
detectives by calling Essex police on
101 also we have two telephone numbers
for anyone with concerns about relatives
to call those numbers are Oh 800 0-5 609
double four for those living inside the
UK and double-o-double for 207 1-5 800
104 those outside the UK we will
continue to issue information as soon as
we're able to but please I do need to
stress that this will be a lengthy
inquiry thank you all very much